I remember as a kid sitting in the
theater thinking oh my God that alien is
so ugly and so weird looking hey I'm
Randall Park and I am gonna break down
my top five Blockbuster movie rentals
so I consider myself an expert when it
comes to movie recommendations because I
used to work at a video store a little
mom and pop called New Way video it's a
neighborhood video rental store also I
play a character who owns the last
Blockbuster and that character is a
cinephile I guess that really says
nothing about my own personal knowledge
of movies but uh yeah maybe I'm not
qualified I don't know
starting at number five better luck
tomorrow
[Music]
if someone came to us about doing a scam
and we didn't like them we just tell
them to [ __ ] off
having that kind of power quickly became
an addiction
the great thing about this movie was
that it was about young Asian Americans
around my age but also that they were
criminals and I thought that was so cool
because we rarely saw ourselves on
screen and when we did it was always
like either the butt of the joke or just
like the side character without much of
a story hardly ever a bad character that
was complex and nuanced and and very
human one image stands out to me is John
Cho riding in on his motorcycle I
remember watching that and thinking oh
man he's so cool I've seen a lot of guys
riding in on motorcycles but never like
an Asian dude with sunglasses looking so
cool
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it first premiered at Sundance at the
Sundance Film Festival there was a
reporter in the audience who stood up
and said how could you make this movie
about your people and then be such bad
people how could you do that to your
community Roger Ebert
stood up and was like what are you
talking about this filmmaker could make
a film about whoever he wants to as an
artist and the whole room ended up like
applauding I think about that a lot in
part because I just directed a movie and
the protagonist of that movie is it's a
complex character who's not like the
nicest person and he's Asian American we
want to see everything the whole kind of
breadth of humanity you know and I think
in that sense better like tomorrow was
ahead of its time
do you remember any of the VHS covers
yeah I remember all the VHS covers
better luck tomorrow was the whole gang
just lined up looking cool kind of black
and whitish
number four E.T the Extraterrestrial
tea
it's depending on Elementary School when
that movie came out like every kid in
the country I was just completely
awestruck I remember as a kid sitting in
the theater when E.T first comes on
screen thinking oh my God that alien is
so ugly and so weird looking I don't
know if I can watch a movie with
something so disturbing and then by the
end of that movie being in tears wishing
that I could see more of that alien
wanting to be best friends with E.T and
that's just like the magic of a great
movie you know that it could actually
like open your mind and let you
intimately know someone but as a young
kid I feel like that's a very powerful
message and I feel like we're all as a
culture very lucky to have had that
movie in our lives wasn't until I got
older that I really got appreciate just
what Steven Spielberg does only like a
master filmmaker could provide that
experience for so many people the VHS
cover
ET of course is a big moon and the bike
with E.T in the little basket up front
number three is boomerang
you're the most gorgeous woman I've ever
laid my eyes on I had to come over and
meet you
I'm sorry
why are you laughing I'm sorry it's just
that uh
what you said was pretty pathetic one of
my all-time favorites you could ask me
on another day it might be number one
but today uh it's number three I just
never seen anything like it it was just
so funny some of the characters were so
outrageous and absurd but it all felt
still felt so grounded and real to me
you know we all grew up with Eddie
Murphy we all loved Eddie Murphy but I
felt like Here Eddie Murphy was like I
don't know there was something very like
exciting about seeing Eddie Murphy in
this context it was about these very
successful black business people you
know in advertising the world felt so
real and the side characters just really
it just felt so full and the cast is
just Bonkers I mean you have Eddie
Murphy Robin Givens a Halle Berry in
like an early role Martin Lawrence David
Alan Greer Grace Jones is an Eartha Kitt
as in it I mean these Legends I mean one
of my favorite characters from that
movie was David Alan Greer's characters
Marx's friend who's kind of like a bit
more kind of uptight but his parents in
that movie I remember distinctly the dad
John Weatherspoon when he's like talking
about you got to coordinate and he has
like the mushroom belt with the mushroom
lining in his jacket I mean that's just
one of so many scenes
so many scenes in that movie that are
just hilarious most people don't record
they see you got the porg boomerang was
one of the influences of always be my
baby because Ali Wong and I have been
obsessed with Boomerang we wanted to
fill it with really kind of fun
characters and we thought of Boomerang
the VHS cover was uh Eddie Murphy if I
remember correctly it was a hand
probably like Robin Givens hand and like
kind of tugging at his tie
number two is the apartment
I've got your dad here for tonight but
I'm going to be using the place myself
so I'll have to cancel cancel but it's
your birthday I already ordered the cake
it is uh directed by Billy Wilder and I
think before the apartment made like The
Seven Year Itch and Some Like It Hot
this movie I got introduced to it I
believe it was through my mom who was
obsessed with movies in Korea American
movies and I think I was just watching
it with her on the couch I was pretty
young and the first thing that really
caught my attention was New York City
and the way it was filmed just thinking
oh my gosh I want to go there I want to
go to New York it's such a like it looks
so cool the apartment is about this guy
played by Jack Lemmon who's one of my
all-time favorite actors he plays uh
CeCe Baxter he's basically like Works in
this office in an attempt to try to be
in good standing with his bosses he'd
lends his apartment to his bosses so
that they have a place to conduct their
Affairs without their wives knowing
this is the mother's apartment that's
right it's a beautiful film and it goes
to Dark Places which I love it's a
comedy it's fun but it's also like very
real in a lot of ways and I really like
it blows my mind that back then in 1960
that you know they would go there for
some reason when I think of the
apartment I can't I don't can't think of
like a specific scene but I think of a
lot of images that have just been seared
into my mind from watching it so much
and one of them is just such this
amazing shot of him at his desk this
like super wide shot of a sea full of
desks and all these workers and him just
kind of toiling away I mean it tells
such a story in a single shot you know
here's a guy he's just a cog in a
machine the apartment cover uh I believe
it was very kind of old school classic
kind of a cut out of Jack Lemmon kind of
looking back and in a lot of words like
you know like they do those old classic
movies
my number one movie When Harry Met Sally
[Music]
said how attractive you are well maybe
she doesn't think I'm attractive
I don't think it's a matter of opinion
empirically you are attractive
quintessential rom-com it is also if not
the quintessential New York movie it's
definitely up there as one of the great
New York movies Billy Crystal Meg Ryan
Carrie Fisher Bruno Kirby I mean the
entire cast is just so amazing I have a
lot of debates with my wife about
chemistry I always felt that if you have
good writing and too capable actors
you'll have chemistry I thought you
didn't believe men and women could be
friends what I say that on the ride to
New York no no no I never said this
yes that's right I can't be friends my
wife feels that chemistry is very much a
magical thing that just exists between
people I see that spark in in the big
final scene you know and Billy Crystal
running to the New Year's Eve party in
his like regular clothes while Meg
Ryan's in this beautiful gown and Harry
delivers the speech I came here tonight
because when you realize you want to
spend the rest of your life with
somebody you want the rest of your life
to start as soon as possible and the way
she looks at him the way he looks at her
I mean it's great acting but to me it's
also yeah it's this great chemistry
[Music]
it's such a wonderful moment and you
know the best kind of rom-com ending you
could imagine
if they asked me
I love the soundtrack and I became a big
Harry Connick Jr fan after that and I
went to go see Harry Connick Jr live
that was the first concert I ever went
to I begged my dad to take me to Las
Vegas I got a ticket with my friend who
was also big into the movie my dad drove
the two of us to Vegas checked in the
hotel room they were just kids went to
see this show and we were just like this
is so cool that was like our like rock
concert you know it was like seeing
Harry Connick Jr in Las Vegas the VHS
cover is actually kind of odd in
retrospect it was like Harry on one side
Sally on the other and I think I like a
big New York building in the middle
they're kind of blown up and I believe
like the cities below them I'm not sure
about that but I'm pretty sure
hey everybody I hope you had fun thank
you for hanging out with me maybe check
out one of these movies I recommended
and make sure you watch Blockbuster on
Netflix
streaming right now
[Music]